this week kicks off Child Abuse
Prevention month it's a way for
Advocates to mark an important reminder
that child abuse can happen right in our
own neighborhood Victoria Saha spoke
with a child therapist to help us notice
the signs and changes that could be a
cause for concern
being the voice for those who find
themselves voiceless the key is Baseline
the key is okay where were they and
where are they now Mandy Bear on CEO of
Mariah Behavioral Health says adults
such as teachers can be the first ones
to suspect if a child is abused as a
teacher I've seen this kid happy go
lucky cheerful interacting now I see
their depressed they're sad they're
anxious they're not interacting Baron
says to be on the lookout for any
bruising that is frequent as for child
neglect Nevada Department of Health and
Human Services says that can look like
if the child has torn clothing left
alone in dangerous situations or appears
to be malnourished to Outsiders it can
be hard to detect abuse behind closed
doors as her 8 news now investigators
have been reporting a teen girl in North
Las Vegas was seen trying to escape her
second floor window to get water that's
when neighbors called police she was
found in a room with deadbolts on both
sides and buckets for bathroom use but
Baron says though a child or teen is
saved from a situation oftentimes
recovery from abuse can be difficult to
escape the abuse or to escape the after
effects of abuse they'll take it out of
themselves you see self-harm you see
suicide you see suicide
um or you see kids taking on other kids
this Friday prevent child abuse Nevada
encourages everyone to wear blue to
bring more awareness to this topic they
say over 2 million children are
neglected or abused each year across the
country